It turns out the answer is 32, which is pretty high.
Here's 1 way to see it.
Let's say that you had invited just 1 more person here, person X.
Then either X shows up or X doesn't.
We already had 8 possibilities with just these 3 friends,
but now we have 8 more where X shows up.
So there was the empty set, the empty list,
but that also gives us the empty list plus person X.
We had just LM, but now your friend X could show up as well.
So if it used to be 8 and you add a new friend, X, now it's 16.
And if you add another friend, Y, bringing you up to 5 friends,
it goes from 16 to 32.
In fact, in general, if you have N entries,
there are 2 to the power of N possibilities.
So there's going to be quite a lot of output.